Alicia
drop on in
okay gosh it's fun it's fun when you
that was neat yeah yeah Dukes of Hazard
Star John Schneider mourning the death
of his wife Alicia Elaine she was 53
years old I am
happier than I've ever been Alicia and I
are happier than I've ever been the
actor revealed the sad news on social
media alongside these two photos he
wrote in the caption my beautiful smile
is pain-free living in her new body
alongside Jesus John asks to share any
pictures of them and their adoration for
each other he ends his post with a
simple message hug those you love tight
and let them know how you feel we always
did Alicia
drop on in
okay gosh it's fun it's fun when you
that was neat yeah yeah Alicia's
obituary says she died at her home
surrounded by Family a cause of her
death has yet to be disclosed but the
couple opened up about her cancer battle
in 2020. this past Memorial Day I was
diagnosed with stage four her two
negative cancer
and within five months and they gave me
very
she was three years into a five-year
shelf life and yeah it's real life and
it's in its ugly part and the big ugly
part for me is I don't know why it's
there
I I
I feel like I have I've been diagnosed
with some kind of cancer and no one will
tell me what it is why it is or where it
is
and um
I'll get through it because of Alicia
John and Alicia Began dating in 2015 she
was his producing partner John and I met
about five years ago and I'm dead about
seven or eight movies together and then
got back into the music industry and did
about 110 songs and then uh just a few
years
fast forward two years the couple tied
the knot in 2019. you take care of
course of course
whoa
sorry
it's all eight dude
dude John penned a lengthy note about
what he's experiencing since Alicia's
death writing grief is much too small a
word I've heard it said that with great
love comes great sorrow I had no idea
what that meant until now Alicia was the
fuel that ran my biggest dreams the
inspiration behind every creative
thought the very fabric of my soul the
glue that held me together I miss her
more than any words could possibly
describe
[Music]
thank you